tens of thousands of farm and
non-farming families alike visit the Ag
Expo every year to check out the latest
Farm Technology trade information and
line up to Chow Down on huge gut-busting
steak sandwiches
farmers are accustomed to changes in
weather and markets and prepare for them
as best they can says third generation
almond farmer Aubrey Bettencourt awesome
a popular farm podcaster and head of the
Almond Alliance Trade Organization at
the end of the day at the farmer's
ultimate goal is to provide a safe and
healthy and reliable product to the
consumer that's what their goal and
drive and entire Mission and purpose is
but some events come with little chance
to prepare an event that most Farmers
could not have anticipated began just
about a year ago when Russia invaded
Ukraine that instantly pushed up the
price of fertilizer
Russia is the world's largest supplier
of nitrogen phosphorus potassium
fertilizer with nearly one-third of all
World production Ukraine and Belarus are
also large-scale producers almost 60
percent or more of the global supplies
from that region instantly the price of
that product went up everywhere in the
world and it became the most expensive
year of farming anywhere in the United
States
farmers of staple grains like wheat and
corn also called maize are heavily
dependent on those fertilizers you look
at corn and wheat specifically the two
categories have been hit the most by the
Russia Ukraine war and those are even
you know it's a perfect storm those are
even more important fertilizer is 35 of
the cash costs of producing those the
result higher food prices and less
profit for Farmers so the farmers
sometimes can't pass the cost on to the
consumer they have to eat the cost of
that rise in the fertilizer cost
the agriculture industry and its
scientific partners are usually quick to
adapt to change whether it be new
consumer demands new technology or
Supply challenges already scientists in
California are working on trapping
nitrogen for fertilizer from Earth's
atmosphere itself Rob Reynolds Al
Jazeera Tulare California